welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition okay the guy who's
like a yo-yo because I always bounce
back and for once because of this
episode I'm not the guy with the worst
puns in the world anyway we're here to
talk about the latest entry of agents of
shield and throughout this video we'll
be discussing everything you need to
know about the show obviously there will
be heavy spoilers here so we don't
anything runed
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now please drop a thumbs up if you
enjoy the video and make sure you
subscribe to the channel for breakdowns
on the show week by week with all that
out of the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the video okay
so the opening of this episode pretty
much shows what happened alongside MCing
dekes excellent adventure with us
getting the perspective of yoyo and co
on board the zephyr now we did
mistakenly say last time that the Zephyr
jump back to save them but sorry for
being a bit a bit of an idiot because
the rescue mission was actually just
them arriving in 1983 and they weren't
purposely jumping back so my bad I'll
understand if you watch some other
basement dwellers breakdown of agents of
shield from now anyway if you're still
here thanks for sticking around and this
episode sort of centers around yo-yo and
her inhuman powers she wants them back
and hooks up with some familiar inhuman
faces in order to do this that's pretty
much the overall part of the episode but
there's actually a lot of notable things
to take from the introduction itself now
firstly because of all the quantum
entanglements that the time drive has
gone through it's now in a worse state
than jada and worlds relationship the
ship does back-to-back jumps early on
and we actually learn a lot more about
what Fitz is doing behind the scenes
he's choosing specific locations to put
the group at but due to this not
happening with this effort we know that
he's not the one controlling its
movements now we don't get to see Fitz
return and actually have a feeling that
he might not even turn up next week
we'll talk about all this when we
discuss the promo for episode 9 but I
think they're saving him for a big
reveal down the line we know that he and
Jemma spent a lot of time working on
things before the start of the season
and I actually think that he's going the
long way
and there's been manually monitoring the
chronic comm jumps wait until they
arrived somewhere before bringing the
Zephyr through I think next time we see
him he'll be an old old man and it's
gonna come as a big twist we get a clue
about this because Jemma says she's not
sure if he'll even get the message that
she leaves for him and with it being in
the 80s in him likely going beyond that
I think that the time difference will
just be too much
now I've either gotten this theory right
or as per usual gotten it wrong so as
always leave your thoughts below as I'd
love to hear if you have any of your own
theories now Jemma was able to work out
what was happening with the jumps due to
her understanding of mathematics and
like a stone skimming across the surface
of water the Leafs were getting shorter
and shorter this is why she told yo-yo
in May at the end of the last episode
that they had a specific amount of days
to get Mack and deep back and she's
clearly worked everything out now in
order to stop these jumps from happening
they need to get the time drive in
stabilize it but there's a rotating
field around it that's disintegrating
all that come close to it and thus they
need yo-yo to get a powers back to
control it also anyone anyone catch
Souza throwing some shade at her saying
way what can you do I caught your Souza
you you don't believe in yo-yo now yo-yo
doesn't know what to do but sky suggests
that they go and visit her mom
aka jiying the leader of the after life
after life is a sort of sanctuary for
Inhumans and we've been there before in
the show so they head out I like how
they could potentially stop Skye from
being born and though Mac's parents were
murdered earlier in the season at least
he was alive whereas yeah at the end of
this you know it's still all up in the
air
they reactivate Coulson before his legs
are fully finished at least we know he's
coming back further down the line as
things were kind of all over the place
with the whole Max Headroom thing now
yo-yo says see you in a minute before
they head out and I thought for a second
that this meant she was definitely dead
because the last time someone said that
in the MCU they didn't come back
maeín yo-yo land outside afterlife and
come across Korra
an associate of ji young called Lee and
a blank teleporter this guy doesn't
really get that much to do the little
moments that he has that are really and
here
and I think the flashes of a moving
reminded me a lot of how Nightcrawler
teleports to so it's good that they kept
this consistency from the comics even
makes a sort of Banff sound so yeah nice
little Easter Egg there now it's from
here that were reintroduced to Ji Young
and if you don't know who she is then
here's a quick ketchup so Jaya Incan
absorb life and thus she's been able to
remain forever young
due to her immortality and living a long
life she gained a wealth of wisdom and
found in humans all over the globe which
she slowly started to lead during this
time she bumped into Calvin Johnson aka
Skye's father and they had a happy life
until she was captured by Hydra and
experimented on much like how Skye was
with Malick after they were done with
her they killed her and chopped her up
into tiny pieces but Calvin was able to
reassemble her and thus she came back to
life now after being cake tested all
over a body she started to hate humanity
and form the afterlife
who were willing to go to war with them
she even started a war with shield which
we get lip service to when Mae talks
about the last time that she saw Quinn
jet I was kind of hoping that Skye would
come face to face with her and perhaps
leader in a different direction but
unfortunately she doesn't in this
episode though they do kind of leave
things open-ended we also see a diviner
which is used to test whether yo-yo
isn't inhuman or not diviners our
containment devices for Terrigen
crystals and they were constructed by
the Kree several were placed on earth
and buried across the planet and during
World War two one was found by Hydra who
called it the obelisk and it was then
taken by the SSR before popping back up
in the show creating Skye yourself and
another inhuman called 'rain jiying
wants to know if inhuman powers can be
removed in some way and this she starts
therapy on yo-yo she discovers that the
problem is psychosomatic and even
proposes a mind meld with may they try
some lovely exercises and almost spoon
but when nothing happens they realize
the only way to get into it is to spar
with one another I guess you really
don't know someone until you fight them
it's from here that we get flashes of
yo-yos memories including the death of
Tess Ruby and her
from my childhood on board the Zephyr
they try and fix the time drive but it
bombs harder than this channel and time
itself becomes sure as the countdown to
it closing in on itself draws closer sky
sits about and looks like crap and they
suggest that she goes to the healing
chamber which looks like it's gonna be
something big in episode 9 Sousa starts
putting parachutes in place in case they
need to jump out and he drops a line
about being a paratrooper in World War
two which is something that he's
mentioned before Jemma presents him with
a new leg so he doesn't have to limp
anymore and I don't know why she's had
this lying around the whole time yet and
you know what yeah Sousa he's slowly
becoming one of my favorite members of
the cast now back with yoyo we learn of
her troubled childhood and discover that
after her father got in deep with the
wrong crowd
she went to live with her uncle and
cousin one of the gangsters tracked him
down and demanded the payment that her
father owed the thug noticed a gold
crucifix necklace which belonged to her
grandma and he managed to steal it back
without him noticing how about the
gangster realized it was gone which led
to him and her uncle fighting over a gun
and uncle died during the scuffle yo-yo
believes that she should have never
taken this and thus she now freezes when
it's time to act it's here that we learn
more about Korra and we discover that
she has highly combustible powers we
learn that Cora is Jang's daughter and
therefore dayz stepsister which is gonna
add an interesting dynamic going forward
after life have been trying to remove
her abilities due to the pain that it
causes and thus the reason they helped
yoyo was to try and discover how to do
this Korra flees to off herself which is
when Malik arrives and destroys a gun as
we know he's been trying to collect
inhuman powers and has been working with
the chronic comms to help to rebuild
them I love how the Malik's have become
the big bad of the season and I'll admit
in hindsight maybe Daisy
should have just killed young Freddie
back in the day now Malik recruits Korra
and his forces storm after life Korra
attacks Lee after jiying tries to calm
it down and they flee to the Quinn jet
and agreed to meet once more down the
line they returned to the Zephyr and
yoyo refocuses a mind realizing that she
doesn't have to hold herself back and
she removes the time drive save
ship like I said at the start of the
video I think this was a play on how a
yo-yo always bounces back and I thought
my puns were bad I know it's a nickname
and that's a line in the show that
they've kind of built up to but I just
removed it from my memory and yeah it
all came flooding back
now sky enters the healing chamber with
Sousa at her side and Coulson powers
down for a few hours though they seem to
be out of the woods Zephyr actually has
another surprise and they jump once more
which takes us to episode 9 in the end
stinger Malick takes over after life to
seemingly harvest all of the inhuman
powers he's pretty much becoming mr.
sinister and I think it's gonna be crazy
when we see what he's like next time
he's probably gonna end up becoming the
most powerful inhuman on earth and he
teases the anarchy that can come from
this Malick was of course missing from
the original timeline after he was
sacrificed to the god of Hydra and this
we really don't know what's gonna happen
with him anyway that concludes the
episode and from this part of the video
we're gonna be talking about what's
gonna happen in episode 9 so if you
haven't watched the trailer and want to
go in his blind as possible then I
recommend that you turn off now okay so
we learned that the final jump is going
to take them to a Time storm in which
the day repeats over and over again as
Skye was in the healing chamber and
Coulson was powered down they're aware
of it whereas the other characters don't
realize what's going on it's Groundhog
Day for the pair and Coulson states that
he's watched all of them die one by one
I don't know if he actually carries out
these murders himself but it does seem
like something more sinister is going on
though he could just be resetting the
day and as painful away as possible we
don't actually see him choking any
characters but yeah the way they cut it
it does sort of seem like that now I'm
kinda in two minds over whether Fitz
will appear in this as it's very
difficult to enter an exit a time loop
in Marvel and I think that the people on
the inside will have to break the loop
themselves by saving all of the
characters from their fate or something
however he could also be the one that
pulls them out of it and he may arrive
at the end of the episode to save them
from being stuck there or he could be
who they come across
on breaking themselves free we don't
know for definite but either way it
looks like another great episode and so
far I've really enjoyed the series I
probably felt that this was the weakest
entry so far but even then it was better
than a lot of the last season so I'm
still riding hard for your season 7 now
obviously I loved you your thoughts on
the 8th episode so make sure you comment
below and let me know if you enjoyed
this video then please drop a thumbs up
and if you missed our analysis of the
last episode then make sure you check it
out after this if you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below as it massively helps us out and
you get access to content early you want
to come chat juice after the show either
follow us at heavy spoilers or click the
discord link in the description below
those are the best ways to keep up to
date with the channel and hopefully we
see you very soon but if not have a
lovely day and don't get stuck in
anytime storms yeah take care of
yourself mate Cheers
you